alright now let's tackle Part C use
quantitative reasoning including
equations as needed to develop an
expression for the new final position of
the block express your answer in terms
of D alright I'm going to set up a
little table here for Part C whoops
sorry about that
sometimes my pin is not functioning
properly alright so Part C let me set up
two scenarios so I have scenario one
scenario one where we compress the
spring our Delta X is equal to D and
then we have scenario to scenario two
where we compress the spring by twice as
much is equal to 2 D and let me set up
my table now so just like that and like
this and let's just think about a few
things so the first thing I want to
think about is the potential energy so
the potential energy when the spring is
compressed so potential potential energy
when spring compressed when I'll just
write compressed when compressed well in
this area scenario I'll call that
potential energy for scenario 1 it's
equal to 1/2 times the spring constant
times how much we compress it squared
now what about scenario 2 this potential
energy is going to be equal to 1/2 times
the spring constant times how much we
compress it it's now twice as much
squared well this is equal to 1/2 times
the spring constant times 4 d squared
and I could put the 4 out front this is
equal to 4 times 1/2 4 times 1/2 times
our spring constant times d squared
which is equal to 4 times the potential
energy when we just compressed the
spring by D so we already see a little
bit of what we talked about in Part B
you compress just
twice as much you're going to have four
times the potential energy because the
potential energy doesn't grow
proportionately with how much you you
you compress it and grows with the
square of how much you compress it all
right now let's think about let's think
about kinetic energy kinetic kinetic
energy when X is equal to zero so right
when the spring when we lose contact
with the spring the spring is no longer
pushing on the block while our kinetic
energy is going to be equal to what our
potential energy was when the spring was
actually compressed all over another way
of thinking about it all that potential
energy has now been turned into kinetic
energy
now what about over here well the
kinetic energy in this scenario like we
just saw before that's going to be equal
to the potential energy when the spring
was compressed where all of that
potential energy gets turned into
kinetic energy and this is equal to four
times u1 four times the potential energy
and in scenario one which is the same
thing as four times which is equal to
four times the kinetic energy in
scenario one so we have four times the
kinetic energy four times kinetic energy
kinetic kinetic energy so then we have
stopping distance stopping stopping
distance we know here this is 3d and
that we know heat and then we can say
well what is this this question mark
well let's just think a little bit about
this we know that if we have that
kinetic energy at x equals zero so we
know that k1 plus the work done by
friction so let me make it clear this
right over here that is work done by
friction work done by friction and it's
going to be negative work because the
force of friction is acting in the
direction opposite of the change in X so
the kinetic energy plus
the work done by friction is going to be
equal to zero this work cancels out all
of this energy it's one way to think
about its turning it all into heat and
so let's think about what the work done
by friction is equal to well the work
done by friction is equal to is equal to
the coefficient of friction times the
mass of the block times the
gravitational field times how far they
that over what distance that force this
right over here is a force of friction
times over what distance that force was
applied so times three D and to be clear
this force is going in the opposite
direction of our change in of our change
in X so because of that this will be a
this will be a negative and so we can
say we can say that the kinetic energy
at x equals zero and now I can just
write it as minus mu the coefficient of
friction times mass times the
gravitational field times three D is
equal to zero we can add this to both
sides and we get K 1 is equal to MU
times M times G times 3 D and if you
wanted to solve for distance here you
can divide both sides by the force of
friction so divide both sides by mu
times M times G and you get 3 D and I'm
just swapping the sides here is going to
be equal to the amount of kinetic energy
we have right at x equals zero divided
by mu times M times G and you could just
view this as the force of friction the
force I'll just call it the force of
friction right over there so if you want
to figure out your stopping distance you
just figure out your kinetic energy
right when you write it x equals zero
right when you start entering into the
friction each part of your of your
platform and then you divide that by the
force of friction and that will give you
your distance traveled so the distance
here distance so I can just put some
arrows right over here our distance
is going to be equal to k2 divided by
the force of the force of friction
well k2 is equal to four times k1 is
equal to four times k1 and our force of
friction is going to be the same we have
the same coefficient of friction we have
the same mass we have the same
gravitational field so divided by force
of friction and this this we already
know K 1 divided by force of friction is
equal to 3 D so this is all going to be
equal to 4 this is going to be 4 times 3
D 3 D which is equal to 12 D 12 D so
this is all a mathematical way of saying
you compress it twice as much you're
going to have 4 times the potential
energy when your spring is compressed
which means you're going to have 4 times
the kinetic energy at x equals 0 which
means it's going to take you're going to
have 4 times the stopping distance so
instead of stopping at 3 D or + 6 D is
what the student proposed you are now
stopping at 12 D so that is our stopping
distance did we answer all of yeah we
answered all of Part C use quantitative
reasoning including equations as needed
to develop an expression for the new
final position of the block express your
answer in terms of D yep feel good about
that